i need to keep pressing you on this how
far are we away from tougher national
restrictions
well i think very clearly the prime
minister has kept setting out
why we need a national framework but
very much a localized approach
you know in different parts of the
country the south west for example the
number of infections is very
is very low in comparison to what's
happening in liverpool
and it's right that there are different
treatments but everything continues to
be considered on a regular basis the
tier levels are reviewed fortnightly on
what might need to change in order to
try and stop people
having to go into the next tier that's
important part of the review process
you have a moral duty as a politician if
people are likely to be losing their
liberty in some form as part of a
national lockdown
circuit breaker whatever you want to
call them to tell them as soon as
possible
well that's why we've taken this
approach of the different tiers trying
to have the national framework but
localized lockdown
as i say we have had votes on this last
night in parliament
about that approach which got the
ringing endorsement of parliament
and it's important that we try and keep
that measured step it's about protecting
lives and about protecting livelihoods
but it is important that people in
different parts of the country who feel
they're
doing their bit have recognized the
national measures are necessary
but there are definitely parts of the
country where the infection rates in the
hospital admissions
are escalating so we're not going for a
national lockdown in portland
i do not believe that the prime minister
wants to set off on a national lockdown
but as ever he is advised by scientists
he takes that decision in the round and
tries understands
and he set out the strategy of national
framework local measures we are not
heading for a national lockdown in the
next two weeks
i don't believe that is the case but as
i say this will continue to be a
decision that the prime minister will
lead on
in order to make that judgment so far we
have the
three tiers and we need to make sure
that we give that the chance to work
the labour leader thinks that we're in
danger of sleep walking into a long and
bleak
winter unless we have a national
lockdown he's wrong
well one of the reasons why we took the
national measures is recognizing what's
coming ahead with winter
other sorts of respiratory viruses that
will be in circulation in the community
so it's taking this approach now in
order to avoid significant problems
later
so that's part of the approach of trying
to have that balance
between as i say lives and livelihoods
but take
a total focus on what we can do to try
and stop the issue
in much more local areas see i'm
surprised you're saying that ms coffey
with all due respect because
um i was expecting you to bat away any
thoughts of
of a national lockdown but what you're
saying is that it's not happening as far
as england is concerned anytime soon
as i say we've got this approach three
tiers uh
again as all these things often run the
review but right
now and absolutely is the way ahead is
to try this
and keep to as long as people stick to
the rules we'll be able to
manage any restrictions locally and
that's what really matters i think
for communities to make sure that they
do their bit locally
the other um states of the uh union at
northern
ireland they look like they're about to
impose a circuit breaker obviously
similar measures being considered in
wales and scotland already has
very strict measures is that not telling
you something
well in northern ireland we're seeing
excess very large rates in places like
derry city
of over 800 um infections per hundred
thousand
that's a massive difference to say
somewhere down in cornwall where it's
considered
nottingham though is very high and
that's why nottingham what got put into
tier two so there is a higher amount of
restrictions
than would be the case in some of their
neighboring counties
are you being influenced by your
backbenchers as opposed to the
scientists
i think that the scientists have been
giving um analysis
for them past many months and
as professor witty said the other day
we're giving some specific
uh evidence and advice on kovid but
chris also referred to the fact that
there are many other factors other
illnesses
other treatments that people need to
have so it's right that the prime
minister
advised by officials advised by his
fellow ministers makes that judgment
call on what is the right approach to
get that balance
of making sure that we tackle uh the
virus to stop the
uh to avoid lives being lost uh but also
continuing to make sure
that for parts of the country where the
level of infection escalation is not as
high
that livelihoods can also be well and
truly protected
in order for this to happen you need the
public to abide by the rules
have you seen the pictures from
liverpool last night i have them to you
again i will certainly show them to my
audience um
thoughts i'm very saddened by it it's uh
it's a city where i grew up it's a great
city and of course the closure today
of uh those bars and pubs where you
can't get a meal or don't have a meal
with what you're going to
drink is a big change for people but
frankly i think it's irresponsible
i think it's just really disappointing
and it's gatherings like that which
unfortunately
don't help in any way to bring down the
escalation of the virus
it's not just in liverpool we've seen it
in other parts of the country as well
we've heard from sadiq khan it looks so
he wants to take
london up to uh tier two we see
celebrations in the heart of
london every weekend if things like that
continue to happen
does that mean that we potentially are
heading for a national lockdown
if they can if young people continue to
party like that what what is the
implication i suppose is what i'm asking
well as i say national framework local
delivery if at some point the prime
minister makes a judgment call but we
are
not in that place we have set out very
clearly localized uh
measures in order to keep that
restriction you know it's not really
fair as i say on the people of south
west or suffolk
when they are doing their bit to try and
control the spread of infections
they've taken on some national measures
which are helping
but those are things that matter i think
in order for communities to keep buying
into the strategy
and to make sure that we can schools can
still be kept open
hospitals can still be kept running
running all those other treatments not
just covered
and that people can freely go to and
from work of course people should work
from home if they can
but it's the element of bringing the
country together to do their bit locally
on
you know hands-faced space and it's
those three key things which if
everybody did it
we'd be able to bring this virus under
control